I wore this soccer suit during the
launch of my Principia mission in
December 2015 and again during my return
to Earth in June 2016 your soccer suit
is connected to the spacecraft's
life-support systems and provides
approximately two hours of oxygen and
carbon dioxide removal in the event of a
cabin depressurization and the suit is
tailored to fit individual cosmonauts we
first wear after soccer spacesuit at the
zvezda factory and this is probably
about a year prior to launch we have to
wear it for about an hour and in during
that time the suit is fully pressurized
so that we can evaluate how well the
suit fits us so it's really important
for the suit engineers to be able to get
the size right so that when you're
pressurized it doesn't cause you any
pain
the soccer shape is contoured for
sitting in the Soyuz couch in a fetal
sitting position and this shaping of the
suit makes it impossible to stand
upright that causes the cosmonauts stoop
as we walk out to the rocket it takes
about ten minutes to get the spacesuit
put on when you're doing this prior to
launch but if you really needed to get
into the Safin suit in an emergency you
could probably get it sealed up in about
two minutes
the gloves are detachable using bayonet
fixings and we wear boots over the feet
only for the walk to the launch the
rigid coat provides protection from
mechanical and thermal impact electrical
and air supply lines and hoses are
connected on the lower abdomen of the
suit and a large blue pressure regulator
is located centrally on the upper chest
with an associated press a gauge on the
right wrist of the suit the spacesuit is
not comfortable to stand up in but it's
actually very comfortable once you're
sat in the Soyuz seat but generally
speaking we wear the spacesuit for the
whole six hours between entry into orbit
and rendezvous with the space station
but I didn't have any problems with
during that time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]